[Music]
so Ricky Gervais is a British comedian
which I can't say I've watched any of
his works or seen any of his shows but
he's an individual who is actually in
line with kind of New Atheism I would
classify him like this and recently he
doesnot sure how long this video has
been up there but I came across this
video which was the second of not the
most viewed atheist
video online or the video with an
atheist title and this is a video where
he's having conversation one of the
American interviewers and there's a bit
of a discussion about God and the
existence of God so we wanted to just
quickly do a reaction video to that and
see if some of the interrogations are
poor for Bhaiji face or in any way shape
or form legitimate the thick you look so
why is there something instead of
nothing that's not the two choices so
the first thing he says was why is there
something rather than nothing these are
not the only two choices well actually
these are not choices at all these are
not choices at all this is a question
it's not giving you is it this all that
because the choice usually is separated
with the word or and why something
rather than nothing is not an
illegitimate question you say it's not
about why but how well if you say it's
not about why and how that would
necessitate that you're starting with a
presupposition which is nihilistic in
other words you conceive the world as
meaningless or purposeless and by that
you say that why questions are
meaningless very similarly like 19:30 is
positivists or even verification estate
the same kind of claim this is a very
weak understanding because if this was
the case then lots of things which would
be meaningless if this is the stance you
take if there's the positivistic stones
many things would be meaningless
metaphysical things logical things
mathematical things so the idea of why
questions being meaningless is something
which has been thoroughly refuted in the
philosophical literature
but the question of its not why but how
okay the question of how so how is there
something rather than nothing it's still
a legitimate question but you haven't
you haven't done any good job in trying
to answer it you've tried to any
question about why is there something
wrong more than one of the most
foundational questions should be at the
forefront of your mind why is there
something at all why is he as if it's
not a good question I wouldn't know why
Albert Einstein would ask those
questions about the explicable 'ti of
the universe that was he an ignorant
person was he someone who didn't know so
once again I think that you're trying to
brush aside some very important and
heavy meaningful and purposeful
questions ultimate questions as Karl
Popper put it in order to try and weasel
will scramble away from those those
kinds of thoughts in your mind Demiurge
that started everything well outside
science and nature I don't believe so
so this is outside of science I don't
think there is a prime mover what is the
word outside of science mean I mean
outside of science is mathematics so
what do you do you think that science is
omnipotent sorry omniscient
that science can explain everything that
through it everything is known so then
metaphysics is out the window logical
precepts are out the window and
mathematics is out though in the outside
of science there's many things that are
outside of science act the scientific
method is outside of science itself the
scientific method through the scientific
method which science depends on is
outside of science so what you're
talking about what this what is this
phraseology outside of science it's just
New Atheists
regurgitate vomited regurgitation which
frankly have no fruitless and futile in
the face of actual argumentations
debate and discussion item is only
rejecting the claim that there is a God
atheism isn't a belief system so he says
atheism isn't a belief system that only
rejects that there is a God even if we
grant that so what what does that do to
the discussion I mean what whether you
want to classify atheism as a religion
as a belief system as an ideology or as
a lacking as its defined of belief who
cares at the end of the day
these are all semantic points I don't
care what you think atheism is or what
you think being an atheist entails the
question still is legit why is there
something rather than nothing and if you
don't answer why how is there something
rather than nothing don't run away from
that okay would you respect don't run
away from the question how means the
definition of how is by what means by
what means can there be
may they be is it conceivable for it to
be or for there to be something rather
than nothing you haven't answered that
question the interviewer I don't know
why I just jumped from one thing to
another
clearly he was deterred by the
confidence of this comedian but he
should have stuck to his guns you said
you know what no no no sorry I'm sorry
how is there something rather than
nothing that's the question so the
general question you saying I don't know
whether it be insufficient but don't
pretend you you have some information
that you don't or try to be strident or
positive about it you don't have an
answer that's it if that's what it is
then that's it don't pretend that you're
someone who's got anything to offer in
this discussion literally if you say I
don't know it means you have nothing to
offer in this conversation you deny one
less God than I do you don't believe in
2999 gods and I don't believe in just
one more he says if there are 3,000
religions I only deny 2999 gods I only
deny one more okay well how many men are
there in the world that could be your
father
wait a minute you trying to yeah this is
no joke this is no joke I mean maybe you
can explain because you're sorry to say
how many men could be your father how do
you know that your father is your father
now you could say oh I can go and do a
DNA test well have you done that I mean
that would be scientific yes and for it
to be truly scientific you'd have to do
the test yourself and see the results
yourself and not depend on only
testimony by the way not the testimony
of the people who do the DNA test for it
to be truly perfectly scientific but how
do you know your father is your father
you know through inference to the best
explanation
wait a minute inference to the best
so the circumstances of you being alive
in that time you're alive and you know
and your father being in the house or if
he wasn't in the house
wherever it was you know how do you know
your mother is your mother same thing I
mean were you there when you were coming
can you remember can you recollect can
you think about the time when you coming
out your mom's room yeah I don't think
you can think about I don't think you
can remember that so how do you know
your mom's your mom see there are maybe
a million people or mini human beings
women that can be your mom and you
reject 999,999 of them and you believe
in only one so that's the same argument
it's exactly the same argument you're
saying I reject 2999 gods and I reject
one more okay that's true so how does
that prove that God doesn't exist how's
that an argument against God's existence
if we take something like any fiction
and any holy book in any other fiction
and destroyed it okay in a thousand
years time that wouldn't come back just
as it was whereas if we took every
science book yes right and every fact
and destroyed them all in a thousand
years they'd all be back because all the
same tests would be the same with all he
says if we destroyed science books and
holy books in a thousand years the
science would be the same replicate but
the holy books won't be the same
actually if you destroy all the quran's
in the world the people would have said
because the Quran is a memorized book is
an overly transmitted book so actually I
don't think it would be gone if you
destroyed them you destroy them all now
people memorize them from a thousand
four hundred years so this this is a
very weak understanding of the
preservation of the Quran or the oral
transmission of it maybe you could argue
that with other religions but you need
to be specific because Islam is you know
a major world religion as you know and
so your argument doesn't actually cut it
when it comes to Islam moreover and
probably more problematic for you is
that you said if you destroy all the
scientific experiments they'll come back
in a thousand years that's a weak
understanding of the philosophy of
science with all due respect because as
Karl Popper mentioned you know there's
the principle of falsification which has
been criticized in the literature by
putting that to the side there is no ink
science is not incorrigibles not
something which is meant to produce
eternal truths see you seem to bring in
this
was referred to as scientism scientism
was the idea that science can explain
everything this is nonsense and there is
some kind of incorrigibly ternal truth
that's nonsense and everyone knows
that's nonsense we know that's nonsense
our experience with the corona virus the
science was changed you're gonna run a
weekly or monthly basis people were
telling us the science says this decide
says that the politicians were telling
us these things and the sciences the
investigations were different because
the sample size was growing and the the
information was changing and the
theories were we're moving around so
science is not incorrigible science is
by nature because it because of the
problem of induction is something which
can be falsified and in time for you to
think that a thousand years all the
investigations that we do today are
going to be the same in a thousand years
time it shows me that you have a
superficial understanding of the
philosophy of science of all due respect
yeah and the same thing applies with
your understanding of the religious
scriptures so put all of this aside well
we're calling you yeah to worship one
God that's what we're calling you to
which is there's an innate
predisposition to believe in one God
Justin Barrett dr. Justin Barrett who is
part of the Oxford or pelagic or
societies run a study in 2011 refers to
this as a in a receptivity to believe in
a God we're naturally inclined to
believe in a higher power you know the
majority of people in the u.s. believe
in a high of 90 percent of people even
the irreligious ones believe in a higher
power it's a natural you know only 5.5
percent according to Linda Woodhead 5.5
percent of the British public Australian
atheist like yourself you you are in a
minority I'm not saying that that means
anything but what I am saying is
sociologically people find it natural
even with the absence of religion to
believe in a higher power it sounds an a
chiral thing it can be argued from first
principles and so to try and dismiss it
as if it's some kind of ridiculous
concept though it's so pervasive
cross-cultural in historically
psychologically and and in every single
way possible I think you're doing a
disservice to yourself and I think
you're just regurgitating and vomiting
out yeah the same new atheist dogma that
you've probably taken from your master
Richard Dawkins
and I'm afraid you're gonna have to
start
can critically for yourself because it's
clear that your arguments are cut and
paste job and they're not even that well
refined as a cut and paste job from the
New Atheists rhetoric so I would say be
more open-minded start thinking start
thinking deeply about three questions
I'm gonna ask you those four you might
think that they're meaningless questions
but I'm gonna put these three questions
to you Rick use your face I'm gonna put
those proof questions to you and this is
way before you go to sleep today I want
you to think about those three questions
I don't say no it's meaningless in
science this is nonsense with disprove
in it and it's not even philosophically
robust the three questions are where
that I come from I think about not just
yourself but the universe itself where
did the universe come from what are they
what are the options either it came from
nothing or something the universe either
came from nothing or something we're
saying it came from something right and
there's no infinite regress so where did
I come from
then what am I doing here yeah so I mean
what is your existence and then where am
I going
you're gonna die I'm gonna die and you
got to think about what's gonna happen
after that if you're wrong you're in
trouble and you are wrong and you are on
and you will be in trouble but it's not
too late this you listening to me right
now Ricky Gervais is actually the best
thing that's ever happened to you in
your life so don't worry come on
you